[Music]
ariana grande goes on a late-night
Disneyland adventure with her now fiance
Pete Davidson that's the newly engaged
couple spotted riding Space Mountain
late Monday
just hours after et learned that Pete
and Ariana are set to marry after just
weeks of dating and what better way to
celebrate an engagement than at the
happiest place on earth
ariana appears to be an engagement bliss
seemingly confirming the news tweeting I
love you so much
this comes shortly after the honeymoon
Avenue singers breakup from rapper Mac
Miller in early May a source close to
the SNL cast member tells et Ariana and
Pete's relationship is fueled strongly
by passion and emotions adding quote
Pete creates this intense relationship
that is moving a million miles a minute
that speed apparently has some of
Ariana's friends concerned though a
source telling et quote Ariana gets so
excited about an idea and so set on
making it happen
that she doesn't always think it through
we fear it was so spontaneous it might
not last
still the couple could keep going at the
same pace our source says Ariana has
always dreamed of a winter wonderland
wedding which might mean Pete and Ariana
say I do before the end of the year
you